I never thought I was going to be an
entrepreneur growing up I didn't have
entrepreneur role models nobody in my
family was an entrepreneur nobody in my
extended family was an entrepreneur I
went to school with people who all
wanted to have jobs you know make it in
the corporate world my teachers all
pushed me towards that path to I never
thought I was going to be an
entrepreneur so I pull up my yearbook at
the end of the year all of the graduates
opens my high school graduates we all
had to answer some questions and some of
them are pretty funny when we flip the
page 5 here so i was asked things i'd
like to forget about my high school
experience and i wrote all of my science
courses what famous quote you wish you
had said to yourself I wrote if you want
to get the fruit you have to go out on a
limb still like that one and the last
one was where do you see yourself 20
years from now let me bring this up
where do you see yourself 20 years from
now vice president of a major investment
bank that was always my dream I wanted
to be an investment banker that's what i
thought was what i wanted to do because
i wasn't exposed to the world of
entrepreneurship it all changed in
university and university i met up with
two people who had a business that
wasn't doing well they asked me to join
as an owner and help them grow this
thing up and i thought you know what you
want the fruit you got to go to a limb
let's try something new and I went for
them and I loved it and and you know
what it wasn't working out at the start
I was making three hundred dollars a
month and struggling that's you know
below the poverty line and an
interesting thing happened in my last
year I got opportunities to work with
merrill lynch and Mackenzie strategic
consulting Merrill Lynch is one of the
top investment banks in the world and
mackynzie was a company that I always
looked up to and admired and so here it
is that this is this is my dream job
right in front of me what I always what
I said in my high school year but this
is what I wanted to have happen and
they're flying me to New York and
they're putting me up in expensive
hotels and they're schmoozing mean
wanted me to join their business and
something just felt off
because i love doing my company and even
though I was only making three hundred
dollars a month I felt like I would
regret it if I didn't go and do that my
own business instead of working for
another company and it was hard and I
struggled with it and I worried that I
would I just made the biggest mistake of
my life and my friends and family
thought it was crazy how could you take
this three hundred dollar-a-month job
instead of going for this eighty to a
hundred thousand dollar a year job right
how could I do that doesn't make sense
is what I always wanted my life and then
you know what I'm so glad I'm so glad
now that I made that decision I had the
you know courage somehow the trust my
gut but I wonder what if I'd never met
those people in University what if I'd
never joined that business I'd be off
doing this thing that is not meant for
me because I never knew if
entrepreneurship was meant for me I
never had a test I never had a guy i
never had that exposure growing up and
so I wanted to help people who are going
through the same thing and I created
Zuba 000 which is the Entrepreneurship
mindset test to help you figure out if
entrepreneurship is is for you or not
you know the help expose you to that
world and what it is is a hundred
questions you go through it and it it
basically by the end of it you figure
out are you supposed to be an
entrepreneur right now or not and you'll
either get a clear indication you know
yes you might get a no and that's okay
that gives you some confidence to you
know to know that it's not for you and
anywhere in between and the in between
is important too because it it'll tell
you where the holes are and you're
thinking it'll tell you where you're
going to fall down in the future it'll
tell you why you're going to be holding
yourself back it'll tell you the people
who you need to surround yourself with
to accomplish your goals they'll tell
you where your fears are going to be and
what you need to overcome to get to
become that successful entrepreneur that
you're after I wish I wish I had this
when I was in high school so I wouldn't
make that mistake I wish I had this when
I was trying to make that decision
between being an entrepreneur
her and working at what I thought was my
dream job this is meant for people who
are struggling to find out is
entrepreneurship really for you if
you're in that zone this is going to
help you on top of the hundred questions
it also shares my story how I got
started it shares stories some famous
entrepreneurs like Larry Ellison and
Jeff Bezos and Martha Stewart and George
Lucas and how they got started and their
challenges and what their advice is to
find out of entrepreneurship is for you
and how to get started I hope you'll
check it out again I wish I had this
when I was going through those problems
and I know it's going to help a lot of
people out so you can check it out in
the link below enjoy it and believe